So far we've seen polynomials. The terms haven't been written in any particular
order. Remember we learned before about the commutative property of addition.
Changing the order that you add terms together in has no effect on the value of
the expression; a plus b is just equal to b plus a. So any set of terms that you
have added together can be written together in any order. And will still be
mathematically correct, regardless of which of those orders you choose to use.
However, there is a convention that people use in algebra to help them figure
out what order to write their terms of a polynomial in. It's pretty simple. The
tendency is to write terms from highest degree to lowest degree. So for example,
if we have this polynomial, y + 6xy. Minus y cubed. We can first figure out the
degree of each term, and then rearrange these terms so that the term with the
highest degree comes first. And then the rest of the terms continue in
descending order of degree. A polynomial written in this way is said to be
written in standard form. So again writing a polynomial in standard form doesn't
make it any more mathematically correct than writing the terms in any other
order. But mathematicians usually find the standard form a bit more visually
appealing and it also can help us understand the polynomial as a whole a bit
more quickly than we could if we wrote the terms in a different order. Since in
standard form the term with the highest degree comes first, we only need to look
at that first term to figure out what the degree of the entire polynomial is. So
that's why standard form is particularly convenient.